hi everyone
this is professor mdos science and today
i want to talk about identical particles
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics identical particles
are easy to understand intuitively
two particles are identical if we give
them the same name for example
all electrons are identical to each
other and all protons are identical to
each other
however electrons are not identical to
protons
at this point you may be wondering sure
but it is rather obvious so what's the
fuss
if you have a system of identical
particles then exchanging
any two particles will lead to exactly
the same physics
this simple statement has profound
implications and they are
vastly different from classical to
quantum physics
in classical physics identical particles
are distinguishable
but in quantum physics identical
particles are
indistinguishable today we will learn
what the precise meaning of these words
is
and that will prepare us to study
systems of many quantum particles
so let's go let's start with the
definition of identical particles
two particles are identical if their
intrinsic defining properties are the
same
so what do i mean by intrinsic
properties
these are the properties that you list
when you want to characterize the type
of particle
and include things like its mass its
charge its spin or its magnetic moment
with this definition all electrons are
identical to each other
because they have the same mass the same
charge the same spin
and so on you can consider another
elementary particle
for example the muon and again all muons
are identical to all other
muons because they have the same
intrinsic defining properties
however muons and electrons are not
identical
because they have the same charge and
the same spin but they don't have
the same mass another example of an
elementary particle is the positron
it is the anti-particle of the electron
and as such it has the same mass
and the same spin but a different charge
so though all positrons are identical
amongst themselves they're not identical
to electrons
we can in fact move beyond elementary
particles to find other families of
identical particles
all protons are identical although they
are not elementary in that they are made
of quarks
similarly all hydrogen atoms are
identical to each other although they
are made of a proton and an electron
and you can continue this way to define
other sets of identical particles
going back to electrons for the sake of
argument note that identical
doesn't mean that electrons are in the
same quantum state
all electrons are identical in that they
all have the same mass the same charge
and so on
but identical particles may be in
different states
for example the electrons may be moving
with different momenta or one may be
bound to a proton to form hydrogen
while another may be free so it is
important to understand this distinction
all electrons are identical but
electrons may be in different states
from a practical point of view what this
means is that exchanging two identical
particles
doesn't affect the properties of the
system
the consequences of this statement are
vastly different for classical and
quantum particles
and this is what i want to explore in
the rest of the video
let's start with identical classical
particles
consider a room such as the one shown
here and i will label the corners as red
blue orange and green
then we place two identical particles
here and here
we give them some velocity so that they
initially move towards each other like
this
then they collide and change direction
and eventually end up here
and here if we look at this situation it
is clear that although these two
particles are identical
in the sense that they have the same
mass charge and so on we can nonetheless
distinguish them
if i call the particle that is starting
near the red corner particle one
and the particle that's starting near
the blue corner particle two
then i can say that in our experiment
particle 1 went from the red corner to
the orange corner
and particle 2 went from the blue corner
to the green corner
so why can i do this i can do this
because i can track the exact
path that particle 1 follows and the
exact path that particle two follows
so at every single point in time i know
where each of the two particles is
so in some sense the labels one and two
that i gave to these particles based on
where they started
behave like intrinsic labels that in
fact allow me to tell the particles
apart
in other words classical identical
particles
are distinguishable if we first exchange
the particles and then run the
experiment
then particle 1 now would be the one
going from the blue corner
to the green corner and particle 2 would
be the one going from the red corner
to the orange corner this is an explicit
demonstration that we can distinguish
these two situations however the physics
of the problem remains the same
when we exchange identical particles if
somebody walked into the room
right before the measurement but didn't
know whether we exchanged the position
of the particles or we didn't
then they wouldn't be able to decide
between these two scenarios because the
physics is the same
so what happens for identical quantum
particles
in this case the situation is
fundamentally different our ability to
distinguish two identical classical
particles is based on the fact that we
can exactly follow the individual
trajectories of these particles at all
times
this is impossible in quantum mechanics
to understand why let's look at a
concrete example
let's imagine two wave packets
describing two identical quantum
particles here
and here these wave packets don't
overlap in a space to
start with so we can initially assign a
label 1 to this particle
and the label 2 to this particle just
like we did for the classical particles
let's again consider a collision between
two particles and in this case consider
the collision in the center of mass
frame
at the initial time t0 we have two well
separated wave packets that don't
overlap
so we can definitely label the particle
on the left as particle 1 and the
particle on the right as particle 2.
just like in classical physics even
though these two particles are identical
their states are different and we can
label them
the particles that move towards each
other and at some later time t1
they will start to overlap during the
collision
the wave packets overlap remembering the
videos on a scattering
at a later time t2 after the collision
we have a combined wave packet of the
two particles that spreads over time
in all directions then imagine that we
place the detector here
and we detect a particle moving outward
in this direction
conservation of momentum immediately
tells us that the other particle is
moving in the opposite direction
but which particle is which when the
wave packets overlap we can no longer
track
particle one or particle two so what
does this mean quantum identical
particles
are indistinguishable
this collision example makes the wave
packet overlap very clear
but any wave packets that don't overlap
to start with will eventually overlap
due to the time evolution of the system
when that happens if we detect a
particle in a region
in which the wave packets overlap we
have no way of telling which of the two
particles it was
what this means is that identical
classical and quantum particles behave
in radically different ways
identical classical particles are
distinguishable
whereas identical quantum particles are
indistinguishable
before we wrap up i want to make two
extra comments first
these diagrams here are very schematic
so you should not take them too
seriously
the state of a two-particle system for
example its wavefunction the position
representation
is described by a six-variable function
which we clearly cannot draw
second i want to emphasize that this is
a fundamental result
not a limitation of how measuring
equipment quantum particles that are
identical
are indistinguishable this has profound
implications for the physics of many
particle systems
and i explored them in many other videos
that you can find in the description
quantum identical particles are
indistinguishable and this has some
profound implications
if you want to see one of the most
mind-blowing ones check out the video on
exchange degeneracy
if you like this video or like send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe